サッブパッパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ
サチッタパリヨダパナン エータンブッダナサーサナン
では 今日のお話始まります
一ヶ月間休んで 頭が錆が入ってましてね
どうなるかよくわかりませんね
一ヶ月間休んでと言ったって
毎日お寺に来る人々に説法しましたけど
その時は頑張って日本で言っている内容を省略して
わかりやすく向こうの言葉でね
言えるでしょうかと思って一生懸命頑張ってみたんだけど
全く認めてくれなかったんですね
なんかみんなえ？っていう顔をしていたんです
普通は私の話を聞いてくれますけどもね
日本でも同じことをスリランカで言ってる仏教をこちらで喋ったら
また同じ結果になります
認めてくれませんね だから認めてくれないっていうことはね
まあ私にもあります やっぱり人間だからね
まあどこかで認めてほしいっていう気持ちはあるんですね
これからこれはもっと深く
まあ仏教の解説はどういう風になっているのかっていうことをね
考えてみましょう 承認欲求の起源
いつからこんな変なことになったのかと
仏教から見れば 古しなる過去から生命は輪廻転生しています
もう初めはわからない
見ても見てまた先があるというね
承認欲求もですから 古しなる過去からある現象です
今更ということじゃないんです
今は日本 現代社会であるよく大きな問題です
そんなことじゃないんです
輪廻と同じです 解脱に達することが輪廻から脱出する脱出になると同時に
承認欲求の問題もその時点まで背負わなくてはならないんですね
なんか文章間違ってますね
まあ解脱に達するとは
私は直します 輪廻から脱出することなんですね
輪廻を脱出したら 承認欲求っていうのは何かね
もうないんです だから解脱に達したら
この承認欲求がないんです
でない限りはあります
それで このなぜあるのでしょうかという
こんなものなんで 生まれた生命は成長するために学ばなくてはならないんですよ
先輩から学ぶんですよ
だから先輩が認めて認めなくては一人前にならないんです
生まれたらこのファミリー誰でもなりますよ
何か認めてもらわないと
だから ちょっと私は言ってないんだけど
なんかあの現代農奴社会でね
私もいろいろ悩むことを聞いてる場合はね
いくら頑張って仕事をしても
会社で認めてくれないとかね
ひどく落ち込んでいる場合とかあるんですね
あるいは逆に人に認めてもらうことばっかしてね
人の目ばっかし気にしてね
なんだこれやっていう風に
ちょっと批判的に見るんですね
否定的ではなくてね これ批判的に見るのはやめましょう
これはもう人間の運命です
微生物はそうではないかもしれません
私は微生物に聞いてないんだからね
よくわかりませんだけど
微生物の寿命はすぐ終わっちゃいますから
生まれては生まれるが
生まれるはまた死ぬが
死ぬは みるみるうちにもうすごい成長も変わっていくんですね
だから学ぶ暇がないんですね
学ぶものもないと思いますね
だからあまりにも低次元的な存在になるんですね
でも犬猫はやっぱり承認欲求ありません
犬のこと知ってるでしょ？猫のことは
認めてあげないと大変なことになるんですよ
もう落ち込んじゃってもう仕方がないんです
私もこの犬猫を飼っている人々に
まあこの間もちょっと注意したんだけどね
好き勝手に喋るなよと
それ気をつけて 犬と喋る時でもすごい気をつけて喋ってくださいと
とにかく言葉がわかっていることはわかりませんだけど
この気持ちの波長がわかるんだから
なんか自分を否定されちゃうとものすごく落ち込むんです
自分の寺にはちっちゃな猫がいて
まあ 1年ぐらいだと思いますけど
捨て...おっぱいあげている間に捨てられ
お寺に捨てちゃったんですね
なんとか餌は食べられる程度でしたけど
でもお母さんのとこ 体に乗って寝たいっていう気持ちはずっとありましたけど
お母さんの猫もいたんだけど
別な子供を産んじゃって
そこでもう私の力もあるんだから
みんなそこでグループ作っちゃって
外の猫たちは追い出すんですね
あの猫がすっごくもう立場がなくて
でも自分には誰かの体に乗って寝たいんですね
だから他のちっちゃな猫たちを追い出すんですね
可哀想だと思ったんだけど
その子もなんとなくみんな寝ていると
ズルズルとあの他の母さんのところに行って
自分も寝ているんですね
で まあ 1年ですからね
結構元気で いまだにあの精神状態があるんで
いつでも怯えて逃げて隠れているんですね
私たちは名前もフクロという名前をつけているんです
隠れているしね 顔もフクロの顔をしてますし
耳もフクロの耳のようになんかとんがっちゃってるしね
可愛いんだけどね だからまあ一生懸命抱っこしてあげて可愛がって
すごく優しく喋り 話しかけたりするんだけど
なかなか餌あげてもちょっと食べてすぐ逃げてしまいますね
だから 認めてくれなかったことをね
ずっと心にそこはあるんですよ
もう残って どうしようもない
これなかなか取り消せないんです
ですから このそれはもう動物たちにもありますね
動物たちは社会を作って群れを作っているんだから
これで認めてくれなかったら
もう立場がないんですよ
ゾウの群れでオスはいつでも一人で生活するんですね
なぜかというと ゾウの群れは全部メスですから
ゾウのリーダーがいつでもメスですからね
相手にしてあげないんですね
オスたちも オスのことはやっぱり怖いですね
ボス オスのゾウが だから一人で小さいといいんです
それで大きくなってくると
青年になってくると もう群れから出て行ってください
だからオスゾウはいくらか凶暴ですね
メスゾウたちはすごくこの決まり守って
しきたりを守って頑張ってるんですね
だから どんな動物の社会でも
そういう風にこの自分の仲間に
認めてくれるということが必要なんですね
カラスの群れすること贅沢ですし
他の鳥たちもそうですし
認めたくない人をいじめて追い出すんですね
ですから これはもう だから一匹のカラスは仲間に認めてほしいんです
一人で生活できないんです
だから何とかして群れに入って仲間になろうとはする
だから私たちよりも状況はすごい厳しいとは思いますよ
猿は必ずそうなんですよ
別な群れの猿が追い出されていっても
他の群れに群れがなければ生活できない
入れてくれないんですよ
だから大変厳しい状況
人間の社会なるいじめもね
その同じ現象なんですね
仲間なのに認めたくない
それでいじめるんですね
だから動物やってる同じことですよ
人間 偉そうな人間 人間やと言ったっても
私はこういうことを言ってみんなに怒られたんですよ
スリランカで説法しててね
あんた方人間やと偉そうなこと言ったってもね
まあもともとみんな獣やった
ただの他の動物と同じやと
これから人間にならなくちゃいけないんだ
人間で生まれませんよと
形だけよと言って怒られたんです
認めてくれなかったんです
私は事実を言っただけなんですけど
私は認めてくれなかったからといって落ち込みはしません
それをネタにしてハチャメチャ言うんです
邪気にね 鬼衆有情という生命がいるんですね
この餓鬼 カミガミ 梵天というところで
だいたいすぐ体が現れるんですね
母親から生まれることはないんです
業でいきなり成人として生まれるんです
それから年取らないんだけど
老いないんだけど 業が終わったらパッと消えちゃうんです
現れたままだから で そこで学ぶことはないんですね
瞬間で一人前の大人で神で生まれるんだからね
でもそちらも社会があるんです
そんな自由がないんです
無数のランクがあるんです
無数の決まりがあるんです
餓鬼道はものすごく自由がないんですね
自分が生まれた場所から移動できませんし
で 移動可能な餓鬼たちもいますけど
他の所に移動したら他の餓鬼たちに追い出されるし
人間の家に入ったら人間もなんとか祈祷して追い出しちゃいますからね
だから 大変苦しい状況やと思います
たとえ天国に生まれても
天国は仏教用語じゃないんだけど
天界に生まれても周りに認めてもらわないと大変です
他人の承認が欠かせない人間社会というテーマです
人間として生まれたならば
学ぶことはしかす問題です
したがって 個人は他人に
社会に認められる存在として成長しなくてはいけないのです
人間にとってはもう大変な問題ですよ
もう学ばなくちゃいけない
学ばなきゃ人間にならないんです
動物は本能でいろんなものついてるでしょ
我々にはないんですね
本能はあるんだけど 本能では生きていられないんですね
知識で 経験で学んだことで生きていなくちゃいけなくなっているんですね
だったらまあ 社会から学んでもらう羽目になるんですね
だから社会が認めたら
他人が自分のことを認めたら
まあ落ち着いて生きられます
あなたのことは何人に認められているのでしょうか
どうですかね 一人一人で考えてみてください
自分のことは何人に認められているのか
3人なんかタイトルが最後に来ますから
なんかハチャメチャですね
今日は 次のタイトルは成功と承認
あの質問の答えできます
最後に出てきた質問に
両親にしか認められない人間もいますね
親だってうちの子はすごくいい子だと認めるんですけど
他誰も認められない 家族
友人 会社などに認められる人間もいる
もっと幅広くで 家族はみんな認めてくれる
両親だけじゃなくて 友人の間でもいくらか認められるし
会社でもそれなりに認められている人々もいますね
わかるでしょう 両親だけ認めている人はすごく暗くて狭いんですね
何もできない人間なんですね
社会はその人のことを拒否しているんだからね
2番目の人はもういくらか生きられますね
それから地方に 地方のみんなに
国に認められる人間もいますね
国全体に 世界的に認められる人間もいるでしょ
もうわかるでしょう 他人に認められることはどういうことかと
これは人の成長を測るバロメーターです
至って簡単 自分がどの程度で成長
成功していますかと 成長していますかということは
どれぐらいの人々に認められているのかということでわかります
それ みんな狙ってますよ
音楽を歌っている人々もね
ヒット作品出したいんでしょ？小説を書く人々もベストセラーになりたいでしょ
そうなった時点で もうなんとかいろいろ小説の場合
いくつか日本で有名な賞があるんですね
いたかなんとか何とかとかね
そこを取った人は それで結構自分の人生がもうしっかりするんです
収入があってもなくても
そんなに大したことないんです
あれだけでも結構立場があるんです
はい それではいきなりもうテーマの中に入ります
すべては自己管理ですというね
失敗する人は世界に文句を言う
だから会社に認めてくれない上司が悪いと言ったら
もう失敗者ですよ もう将来はないんです
仏教はいつでも他人に指を指すんじゃなくて
自分に指を指してくださいという世界の自分を見なさい
自己観察しなさいというのが仏教なんです
ダンマパダの偈がありますよ
ナパレーサンイローマイナパレーサンカタカタ
他人の過ちを見るなよ
あれが悪い これが悪い
あれがいけない あの人やってる
あれが何であんなことやって見るなよ
そんなこと 他人がやったこと
やらなかったこと そんなことは置いておいてください
あったのはアヴェッケーヤ
自分を見てください カタにアカタアニケ
自分がやるべきことをやっているか
やってはいけないことを本当に守っているのか
自分を見なさいというのは仏教なんですね
ブッダの言葉なんです
ですから そのブッダの言葉に沿って
このテーマを説明していきましょう
はい 次のテーマを言います
管理不可能な社会世界
これは管理できないんです
大体なく項目だけいきます
他人は好き勝手に行動します
他人というのは その人が勝手に行動するんですよ
認証するべきなのに認めなかったり
認証するべきではない人を認証したりもします
世の中 そういう世の中なんですよ
他人がすごいわがまま
自分勝手 だから会社の部長であろうがね
勝手 自分の部下はちゃんと客観的に調べて評価しようとはしないんです
随分好き勝手 これ管理できない
上司にアドバイスすることできますか？部下に
上司はしっかりとみんなの仕事ぶりを見て
客観的に評価しなさい
評価する方法はこういう方法だよ
言える？言えないです
自分が部下だから 上司には上の人はそれ言わなくちゃいけないんです
だから部下にとってはお手上げ
もう上の人好き勝手にやってるから
そこで自分の上司の部下も同じこと
好き勝手 悪いことをしているのに
自分の部下が まああいつは仕事できるんだから放っておこうと放っておくんですね
そうすると 一番下っ端の仕事の人ってやられっぱなしでどうにもならない
いつでも社会にある現象なんですよ
私を認めなさいと他人を責めることは不可能です
事実でしょう 私を認めなさい
認めなさいと 夫婦の間でもよく喧嘩になって離婚までなるんですよ
ただ それ 認証の問題ですよ
承認の問題です 例えば奥さんが一生懸命家のことをちゃんとやっている
旦那さんにこれ認証しなさい
認めなさいと要求するんですね
口で言っちゃうと味がないんだから
ね いろいろやるんですね
男も男でわがまま好き勝手に
そんなことは奥さんの仕事で
仕事 俺は俺の仕事していて
お前は自分の仕事をしてれば別にいいんじゃない？それっていう
すごいそういう態度だと思うんですね
これで離婚で終わっちゃうんですね
だからこれ大変ですよ
というわけで 社会は管理不可能です
世界は私個人に管理できません
とまず覚えておいてください
では私はどうするのか
それから自分に問題が来るんですよ
これってそんなに大事な大した問題じゃないんですよ
例えば 川は私たちにはそんなに管理できません
川は流れる 川を渡りたいと思っても
川が私たちを渡してくれません
だから川が勝手に下へ下へ
海へ海へ流れるんだけど
私たちはそれなりにボートに乗ってなんとかして向こうに渡ってみるんですね
じゃあ川が邪魔したかというと
あんまり邪魔してもないし
なんかよくわからないね
川があるから渡れたしね
まあ川がなかったらボートはいらないしね
だから川が邪魔したんだから
我々はボートに乗っちゃったんですね
で ボートに乗ってからは
川を使って向こうまで渡っていくんですね
だから そこは社会の場合も同じことで
我々は社会をうまく渡らなくちゃいけないんです
社会に指をさして指令するんじゃないんです
川にあんたもう水を止めてください
私はこれから渡りますから
これはありえないんですね
雨が降ってると これやめなさい
今私は出かけなくちゃかんないから
これはありえないでしょ
だから個人の指令は社会効かないことで世界は成り立っている
もしある人の好みのように自然が変わっちゃうと
とんでもないことになるでしょう
だから この独裁者の国々ではよくあることでしょう
独裁者の指令で わがままで好き勝手に国民を責めちゃう
だから独裁国家 どんな国家でもとんでもない国になるんです
誰も幸福にならない 北朝鮮とかね
中東のイスラムの国々とかね
ほとんど独裁国家 毎日殺し合い
テロやあれやこれやとか終わりがないんです
これ テロ行為をやっている人々も
独立のために 民主主義のためにテロをやっているんじゃないんです
この独裁者を潰しちゃって
我々は独裁政権を取らなければならない
だから人間の社会では
もうこの社会を支配しようと管理しようとすることはとても危険なことなんです
だから我々は社会 人間を含むすべて自然界として見ているね
この自然界は味方でも敵でもない
はっきり言えばよくわからない
そこで我々は 私はどう管理するのかと
ほんのちょっと土地があったら
いろんな植物が生えてきますよ
困ったな 困ったなと思ったら
自分がそのいらない雑草を取って
自分に必要な野菜とか花とか育てればいいのです
だから言って指令することはできないんですね
そういうわけで この最後の文章を覚えておきましょう
私を認めなさいと他人を責めることは不可能です
同じタイトルです 続けます
自分個人のことを社会は知り尽くしてないんです
でしょ 自分個人のことを社会は侵束してない
これは子供のことを親が知らないんだから
たとえちっちゃな子供であっても
赤ちゃんであっても 赤ちゃんのこと母親は全部知らないんです
だからいろいろトラブル起こるでしょ
子育ての場合はこのトラブルを起こす
のは知らないから泣いているんだけど
なんで泣いてるんですかと
わからないんですね だから
あれこれやっていろんなことをするんですね
自分が泣き止んで欲しくてやったことは
子供にとっては外れだったら
子供はもっと力入れて泣くんです
だから赤ちゃんのことをわからないんだから
もう産んだ母親も赤ちゃんのことはわからない世界だから
旦那に理解してほしいと思うのはどういうこと？理解してできないんですよ
男たちは堂々と言うんですよ
そんな話は 女って全くわからないんだと
今夫婦生活はもう 25年ですけどね
あいつは何考えてるの？さっぱりわかりません
はっきり男は何の重苦もなく読む
それは事実です 自分のことは自分でもよくわからないのに
他人が正しく理解するはずがありませんよ
だから 私の方であなたはあなたのことを知ってますかと
知らないでしょう だから仏教を実践して
実践して 長く時間経つと
まあ自分のことはよく知るようにはなりますけど
それでも業が絡んできて
いろんなことをやっちゃうと
それでも自分には管理できない
業が絡んでくると思考が変わるんですね
思考が変わっちゃうと結果が即応する出ます
だから 自分でも自分のいくら自己観察しても
自分のことをわからないところはあるんですね
お釈迦様の場合 たくさんのエピソードがあるのは
そういうポイントを示すためなんですね
そこで一生懸命修行しても
修行してもなかなか解脱に達しない
自分でわからない なんで頑張っているのに
何の問題もないのに それでお釈迦様のところに行くんですね
お釈迦様は人のことを成熟しています
ブッダダンマ触れてというんだからね
えーと なんとなく人 人
えーと 育てることにおいては最高な能力を持っている
だからお釈迦様は一言言ったら
それで悟りに達するんです
お釈迦様でないケース
一つ経典にありましたけど
有名なアローダ大阿羅漢が名前忘れちゃったんだけど
一生懸命瞑想するんだけど
するんだけど 悟りに達しない
自分を自己観察するんですね
戒律は ok 精進努力することは
それは完璧にやっている
頭が混乱してたりはしない
雑念妄想割り込んでこない
瞑想はうまくいっている
しかし 解脱に達しない
そこで アンルデサンジャラ
大阿羅漢 誰かのところに行ってね
困りましたと 私は本当頑張ってるんだけどね
解脱に達していないんだ
じゃあ長老の答えはね
あんたね 解脱に達したいという気持ちを捨てなさい
解脱に達したいという欲求があると
あなたの心に情動が生まれるんだと
集中力壊れるんで 情報っていうのは心を混乱するんですね
うまくいってない 失敗した
あの微妙なところ だからその気持ちを捨てなさい
言って 落ち着いて注意しなさい
そこでその方がやっぱり目的を決しちゃったんですね
解脱に達すると目的を消しちゃったところで
すごくリラックスしちゃったんです
ただ普通にやればいいと
すぐ悟るんです だから自分のことをわからないっていうのは
偉大なる人物にもあるものなんです
お釈迦様以外は だから私たちは大きな間違いするんですね
社会は自分のことを理解してほしいとかね
自分を正しく評価してほしいとかね
これはありえない そんな能力社会にないんです
私のことを理解してくれませんと泣くことはやめましょう
いいんですよ だから私は 1ヶ月間も認めてくれなかったという経験があるんだからね
泣いてないんです そこで人間が
社会がいい加減 あまり物事をわからない
これ読める人間いるんですよ
この人はここら辺はわからないよ
それで自分が認めるために
変なこと 狡猾なことするんです
だから狡猾は自己破壊の道というタイトルですが
覚えておいてください
社会の一部を騙すことはできても
皆を騙すことはできません
わかりやすく言いましょうか
例えば 上司が何か二人に何とかこのレポート書いてくださいと
何か調べてレポート書いてくださいよ
二人でやってくださいと
で この二人の一人が お前データ調べるのが上手だからね
まあちょっとデータ全部調べてください
で まとめてください どうですか？どうですか
どうですかと見てみて
よくできている場合は
本人がそれを持っていって
上司に上司出来上がりましたから
レポートは自分が出すんです
なんか自分頑張って何もやってないから
それでその時ああ よくできている
で そうして困るんですね
そういうのはすごい狡猾的なする賢いやり方なんですね
やってますよ 私にもそういう経験結構あるんです
ある人がもう今結構立場があるんだけど
頭がすごく悪いんですね
私から見れば 私の判断ではね
それで大学院で研究したりになって
私は何やりたいんですか？って言ったら
すごい難しいことを言うんですね
要するに この人にこんなテーマできるわけないでしょ
ただ テーマ変えたらどうですか？って言ったら
本人に研究できるテーマいろいろ提案したんだけど
あまりにも我が強くて認めません
これでこれやりたいと言って
レポート出さなくちゃいけないんだから
ちょっと教えてくれと
そしたら教えてくれるのが面倒くさいんだから
私はサーッとアップで
日本で送ったレポートなんですけど
英語で全部シノプシスとモリアスと書いちゃったんです
私が書いたらもう一応一応
そう ファーストグレードなんです
どんな教授にだっても何も文句言うところは欠陥はなし
これ書きながら 私はこれは相当な能力が必要だと
このデータ調べて研究するために
しかし そのレイアウトだけででもかなりのデータがあるんです
それで この人 私はこれは出さないでください
あなたは自分にわかるように日本訳して
私は当時そんな日本語もできませんでしたし
日本語に訳して出してください
ああ できます できます
でも英語もできない だから学問英語だから
当人にこれ日本語に日本訳することはできない
あの B と言いますけど
日本人ではないんです
日本人はそこまで汚いことはやらないんです
で まあ学生たくさん知ってますから
日本の学生さんたちは研究する人ってすごい真面目で真剣に研究をしています
まあふざけるやつはでもだってもふざけるんだからね
それは大きな問題ではないです
で 学部の学生はね 人のレポートをね
もう丸ごとコピーして出しちゃっても
あんまり大学の先生で気にしないんですよ
とにかく卒業して社会に出したいんだからね
自分たちの子供たちを
大学入になってくると
それは甘くないんですね
それでこの人はこのままだったところで
教授たちがみんなこれを回し読んで
なかなか素晴らしい研究テーマだと
素晴らしいシノプシス社といって
私に読んだんですね あんた知ってます
なになにさんが素晴らしい人ですよ
私はどう返事すればいいかと調べたら
私が書いた文章そのままだって
それでその人は結構立場取っちゃったんだけどね
だからそういうことはやっぱりしちゃうとまずいんですよ
いつでもできるわけじゃないんです
騙して認めてもらっても
その人気は短命です よくあることで
この博士とか取りたいと
あるいはまあ人に頼んで論文を書いてもらっちゃうとか
インドでもよくあるし
よくあるやってますよ
私はそんなにだけど ただ
博士って大抵肩書きだけ欲しいんです
私は結構博士の連中を見たことあるんだけど
私はまあ高校ぐらいは能力あるんですね
こいつはという態度なんです
私はすごい態度悪いんです
この人たち だから私はこういうことで
ああそうということで終わっちゃうんです
だから結構私の人気は最低
で認めますけど まず私はいろいろ質問するんです
あなたの研究分野は何ですか？何を研究したんですか？何を発表発見したんですか？とかね
どんなそれには何もわからない
なんだこりゃ 誰かに書いてもらったんじゃないんですか？と
すぐ読めるんだから だからそういう風に学位取っても
人の前で喋れないし 自分のテーマについて何かしゃべってくださいっちゃうと何もできないし
今もいろいろ連絡来るんですよ
なんとか書いてくれ 書いてくれ
有名人なんで 自分の分で
自分の研究してる分野で
なんで私は関係ない 私がやらなくちゃいけないんですか？だからまあ大変ですよ
そういう人気はあんまり短命です
学ぶために使うべき能力を騙すことに使うと
人は悪になってしまうんです
だから人を騙すためにも知識が必要です
学ぶためある知識を騙すことに使ってしまえば
より馬鹿になっちゃうんです
それは仏教では悪行為なんです
ものすごい悪行為なんです
戒律では嘘の戒律ですからね
完全な悪行為です 完全っていうのはちょっと完璧な方法です
だから承認欲求は誰にでもありますが
だからといってフォーカスなことをやってはいけないのです
タイトルは最後に フォーカスは自己破壊の道
はい それからですから
私たちは社会に認められるように生きていなくちゃいけないんですね
これについて社会に認められるようにということを考えてみましょう
それでも社会に認められるような生き方をしなくてはならないんです
ブッダの言葉 ナチャーフナチェバビッセットィナチェエーカラエビッジェティ
エーカンタンニンディトーポウソ
エーカンタンワーパサンシポ
ダンマパダ二百二十八
完全に非難される人も
完全に称賛される人も
過去にも将来にも現在にもいません
それを覚えておけば気持ちいいんです
お釈迦様はネッチャーフ
過去にもいなかった ナチェバビッセットィ
将来も現れません ナチェエータライビッジェティ
今もありません エーカンタンニンディトーポウソ
極端に批判されるべき
悪人はいません 逆に極端に社会が人類が称賛する人も存在しない
それはお釈迦様にしても同じこと
お釈迦様は完全な人格者でしょう
お釈迦様の能力はどんな人間にも
神々にも誰にもないでしょう
だから完全に称賛されるべき人格者なんですが
非難する人々は結構いたのです
はい まず私たちはこの教えをよく理解して
まあたまたま非難されたってもね
あんまり気にしない 称賛されたってあまり気にしないということでいた方がいいんです
なぜならば 相手が例えば私を非難侮辱する方々
日本にもいるしね でも私はそこを読んでみたら
この人々はまあいわゆる好き勝手なことを妄想してしゃべっているだけ
私は行ったこともない
やったこともない いろんなことをこうやっていると書いたのに
どうやって知っているのかいと
私はナイショでもやらないことばっかり書いていたので
だから ああ なるほど そういうことかと
それからもう一つ ブッダの言葉
ナッティローケアニンディトー
非難されない人はいません
それもブッダの直々の言葉です
ナッティローケ この世の中で非難されない人は存在しない
誰だって非難されますね
アメリカのオバマさんどうですか？言われるでしょう
政治家としてしっかり活動している
あのロシアのプーチンさんどうですか？政治家としてはものすごい能力なんです
非難されます 誰でも同じこと
中国の習近平だって同じことじゃん
はい これでまあ基本的なところ終わりまして
まあ一応実践するところに行きましょうか
この自己管理の仕方 では
どうやって我々は自己管理するのかね
この気をかく自己管理はこの承認の問題なんですね
心を育てることに専念する
だから承認してほしいと思うならば
私たちの仕事は自分の心を育てるしかないんです
そうすると やっぱり社会が曲がりなりに認める
例えば嘘をつかないことにする
いろいろ都合の悪いところもある
損するところもある そういう周りがお前バカじゃないか
なんでそんなこと言ったんですかね
違うと言った方が良かったのにとかね
言うかも でもどうかで
あの人 本当に正直で嘘言わないねとか
結局は褒められる バカにもされる
バカにされるんだけど
褒められる 例えば酒飲まないと決める
しっかりそこを守る お前たまたまいいんじゃないんですかねとかね
この場合もせっかくだからいろいろとやらない
頑固やとかね 人付き合い悪いやつやとか
いろいろ言いたくなります
でも逆にこの人決めたことをやるんだよという
称賛も出てくる これ両方出てきますよ
一つだけじゃない はい
自信がないというテーマ
だからこれは普通ですと書いたって何か分からないでしょうね
タイトルは自信がないなんです
で 自信がない これは普通です
自信がないということは
客観的に物事を観察するならば
何に対しても自信が起こる
はず ほぼ数はありませんが
なんか文章言ったこととは違うことを書いているような
あの物事を客観的に調べてみると
いくら高い高い深い知恵で調べても
発見する結論は自信っていうのはなかなかないのです
私はじゃあ あの裏の言葉を言います
すべて無常です だから先がわからないんですね
そういう現象の世界の中で
どうやって自信を作れますかね
だから自信がないっていうのは
頭が大丈夫やっていう意味なんです
正常です 自信があると言ったら
よく注意した方がいいんです
自信がないこといいんです
自信がないからこそ努力するんです
だから成功に達するまで努力しなさいとブッダの言葉がありますよ
わやめというクリストアヴァッタセニッパダ
で 自分の目的に達するまで諦めず努力
精進努力しなさい そういうわけで
あ 私はこの試験は合格する自信がありますと言っちゃうとアウトなんです
勉強しないんだから やっぱり自信がないねとかね
もうちょっと勉強したいなとか
もう一度繰り返してやりたいなとかね
もう一度試してみたいなとかね
そういう人が末端で合格するんです
だから我々はこの単語の使い方ね
なんでもこの何て言いますか
このネガティブで悲観的に見るんですね
何一つも悲観的に見る必要はないんです
何でも使い方次第で役に立ちます
だから使い方次第なんですね
悲観的なのは何もないんです
です 自我の錯覚が強い人の場合は
自信がないことに気づくと精神病に陥ります
自信がないことは精神病になっちゃう
その人 自我がありすぎる
錯覚が 初めからの正常じゃないんです
だから胸は自信があるわけないでしょという風に言った人がものすごい明るいんです
私はこの 1ヶ月間 子供たちと付き合っていたんだから
子供たちに何かしてことを頼んじゃうと
どうたってもハチャメチャなんですね
で それ知ってるんだから
やっぱりまあハチャメチャしてるんだからどうったことないんだけど
我々大人から見れば でも子供といたっては失敗したという気持ちが私は与えたくないんですね
それで私は何するのかというと
そんな子供だから すごい胸張って自信がありそうなできますできますって言うんですね
私は徹底的に自信壊しちゃうんです
自信壊しちゃうんです
できるわけないでしょとかね
やっちゃったらハチャメチャになるでしょうとかね
こんな結果になるでしょうとか
もうわずかでも自信がないようにするんです
そしたらこいつら じゃあやってやると
やってやるのに完璧にやるんです
結果はいいんです だからそうすると
私は嫌なんですけど うまくいったね
これはとかね こういう風に言うんですよ
ちょっと何か失敗しちゃって
だからそこでまあ その子供たちの人格が
まあ親にできませんよ
私と一緒にいると まあ 2日 3 日ですごく成長するんです
だからこの自信がないや
やりたくないというかね
批判される いろいろ言われる
病気です 言われますよ
いろいろ 私は純粋なブッダの言葉
もう日本で他外国人誰にもできないで
この仕事は 日本人もパーリ
あれこれ勉強したっても
私がやっている仕事はできないと思いますよ
だからみんなね 賛嘆してすごいと思った方がいいでしょ
ないんで 思ってないんで
誰も 言われますよ 言われるんだから
私はやめる？やめません
だからそれは世の中の生き方なんです
例えば日本でもごちゃごちゃ言われるでしょ
安倍さんのことにしたっても
安倍さん いろんなね もうツイッターやらいろんなところでハッチャメチャ悪口言ってるんだからといって
私は嫌になっちゃった
総理大臣辞めますと言う？言わない
やります だからそういう
人々は社会で成功者たちでしょ
この非難を受けるということは
特に政治世界ではね ものすごくありますよ
いろんな政党があるでしょ
だからみんな勉強している立派な方々ですよ
みんな立派な方々なんですけど
はちゃめちゃ悪口言われた
もう悪口言われるんだから
私はこの政党をやめますとかね
解散しますとかありえないんですね
例えば日本人の中で全然人気ないでしょ
共産党は 共産党の方々は言っていることはものすごいしっかり言ってるんです
すごく調べて すごく言ってますけど
日本じゃないから人気ないんです
でも一度たりとも共産党は解散しようと思ったことある？ないんです
議員の数もほんの一人
二人 三人程度で 私はびっくり
それでも選べるのは不思議やと
こんなに人気ないのに
だから言われるのは当たり前なんですね
逆に言われる 批判されるということは
自分が頑張っているんですね
無視できなくなっているんです
社会には無視しようと思っても無視できないんだから
社会はものすごく非難
侮辱 やってるんですね
はい 自信がないということはそういうことで
自信成り立たない いくら頑張ってもね
例えば会社を経営しようとする
繁盛するかしないかを全くわからないものでしょ
品物を何か開発する ヒットするかしないか
分かったもんじゃないんです
歌を作る人々はね 一生懸命自分の妄想の世界に入り込んじゃって歌を作るんだけど
これヒットするかしないか
誰がわかるんですかね
だからまあそれは自信がないってことなんです
次のタイトルは自信を確信に置き換える
自信を確信ということに置き換えます
なんか漢字で見ると 確信
自信よりは強いんか自信
確信というのは まあ私はちょっと英語で考えちゃったんだけど
confirm なんですね
確認は確信は確認と同じ働きです
英訳すると confidence and confirm confirmation
is confidence ということになるんですね
出かける時 鍵を閉めたかどうか確認しましょう
しかし 絶対強盗が入らないとは言えないね
窓もちゃんとロックして
そこで確認しましょう
はい 窓を閉めたとかね
私は窓 2つ開けてきましたけど
3つ それで はい 窓を閉めた
鍵かけた 鍵かけてからもう一度引いてみてもいいんです
再確認 ちょっと開けてみる
あ  OK 時々あるんですよ
この鍵をかけちゃったんだけど
中に入る あの 何て言いますか
もう部品がありますね
ターンと言いますけどもね
あれは入らないっていう場合もあります
だからちょっとドアを開けて開けようとみた方がいいんですね
だからそうやって 1回 2
回  3回確認するのはいいんです
なんで？自信がないからです
自信あると我々はものすごい妄想しちゃって
さっさとは出かけましょうだって出かけちゃう
鍵かけてない だから自信ではなく
この 確認して確信する
仕事 勉強 料理 洗濯など確認しながら行う
行うことに確信があれば十分です
料理する場合は まずこれこれぐらいの 100g これって言って
こういう風に切って塩をかけて置いておくとかね 10
分  30分ぐらい冷蔵庫に入れておくとかね
それ確認する 醤油小さじ 1杯と塩をこれぐらいとかね
それ一つずつ確認してやれば
料理は失敗する可能性はものすごく少ないでしょ？あ
入れ忘れちゃったとかね
入れ忘れるのは自信がある人々なんですね
それ何か入れ忘れちゃう
自信がある人は 買い物に行ったってもいくつか忘れちゃいます
私もやってないんだけど
買い物に行く場合は一応これこれこれ買うんだ
買うんだと書いてもった方がいいんです
なんでメモを書いておくんですか？自信がないからでしょ
でもその人は何か買い物を忘れることある？ないんです
私の場合ありますよ あれも買わない
これも買わない あれもあれもあれもと頭の中にあって
その時間ができたら じゃあ買い物行きましょうと言って
目に入ったものを買って帰って
あとであれ買い忘れ あ
これも忘れちゃったとかね
あるんです 私の場合は
一つだけ品物を買おうと言ったら忘れません
いくつか買おうかなで言っちゃうと何か忘れます
だから私はそれを全然へっちゃらと思ってるんだから直せませんだけど
そんなのは嫌ならやっぱりメモを書いた方がいいね
私はメモを書かない理由があるんです
何か買い物のリストを書いちゃうと
書いた時点で頭に刻まれるんですよ
忘れないんです だからなんでこれ持っていくのか
面倒くさいんです はい
それでも生活の仕方がわかるでしょう
自信は要りません 確認する
確認すると確信が生まれる OK
大丈夫 それはすべての物事に
仕事をする時でも ちょっとチェック入れる
チェック入れるでしょ？これ OK
はい これチェックとかね
外国に行く場合でも 最低パスポートとチケットの番号ぐらいチェックしておきましょう
私もまあチケットを印刷しようかなと思ったら忘れちゃって
間違って別のものを印刷しちゃって
これはもう番号なかったんで
それでメール見たらメールにちゃんとチケットありましたから
じゃあまずそこを出して
メールの中から持っていって
空港に寝て そのまま来たんです
で パスポートをチェックする
他いろいろ忘れて だから持ってきたいものがいくつかありまって忘れちゃったんです
まあ別にいいやということはしたんです
自信を確信に置き換えるというテーマですね
ちょっと早く行かないと
次はこの承認の必要があるなしの区別
あのね 必ずしも承認が
自分のすべてに他人の承認が必要ではありません
何でもかんでも人に認めてほしいと思っちゃうとね
これまずはありえないし
自分がもう壊れてしまいますよ
人は承認しなくたっていいんです
何でもじゃないんです
これ区別します 瞑想することも
戒律を守ることも みんな求めるのではありません
皆さんもね 戒律を守ったり
瞑想したりするでしょうに
結構家族とかみんないろいろ言われるでしょ
いいんです 別に わかってないんだから
しかし 人は何言ったっても
私は麻薬使いますよと
麻薬使いでどれほど気持ちいいこと
あんたわからないでしょうと
その態度は良くないでしょ
その場合は社会に非難されるんだから
麻薬をやめる しかし 戒律を守る
道徳を守る 瞑想して精神を育てるとかね
人にいくら馬鹿にされたってもいいんです
あいつは変な瞑想をやっているんだ
だから何やと だからそこでこれは親が反対してもやるべきこと
これは親が反対するからやってはいけないことというふうな区別が必要なんです
しかし 自分の仕事 作った料理
勉強 知識などは他人の承認が必要です
料理作ったりしましょう
これでいいと勝手に思ったってもね
食べる人はこれちょっとまずいと
味が濃いすぎやと もうハチャメチャになってるんだと
それダメなんですね 料理作ったら
誰が食べてもおいしい
よくできているという他人の
その場合 他人の確信が必要です
仕事はどうですか？自分勝手に仕事をしても
これ会社がこの仕事は OK ですと認めなきゃ
いろんな品物を買いするでしょ
品物を買いしても 社会がいい品物ができちゃったとかね
あれがいいものや買いましょうというふうに社会が認めなかったら
自分勝手にいいことを作っちゃったと
意味がないんです しかし
勉強はどうですかね あれはよく勉強してるんだと勝手に言ったって誰も認めませんね
だから自分が勉強したことも
自分一人でやったことなんですけど
それは社会が認めなくちゃいけないんです
これは例です 自分で作成した大学卒業証明書は無効です
でしょ だから学問は先生に認める必要があります
そういうことで タイトルはこれから入ります
承認の必要があるなしの区別
これも勉強しておきましょう
人は認めないことなんですが
いうことはあるんですね
例えば誰かさんが若者がスワヒリ語を勉強しようとする
周りみんな馬鹿にする
スワヒリ語なんでと 何に使うのかと
それでもその人はそこを勉強
しっかり勉強したら仕方がないでしょう
どこかで役に立つ可能性ありますね
次のタイトルは個人の義務を果たす
自分の義務を果たすだけで人生は精一杯です
一人一人やらなくちゃいけない義務がいっぱいあるんですよ
それだけでも我々は精一杯です
それ以上妄想するものではありません
あれやこれやと妄想やめましょう
みんなに認められませんとかね
聞き目がないとかね なんで無視されているのかとかね
なんでいつでも私のことを批判ばっかりするんで
そんなのはどうでもいいんです
自分の義務を果たすと時間終わっているんです
やることなかったら 自分一人で本を読んだり
いろいろ勉強したりした方がいいんじゃないですかね
この余計なことを妄想しないで
ある程度で認められたら十分です
不完全な世界は完全な人間を認めません
これも覚えるべき文章です
世界は不完全です だから完全なものは認めません
変でしょ 自分たちが不完全なのに完全なものできたらよかったよかったと言うべきところ
逆なんです だから 例えば私に何か能力があるとしましょう
すごく桁違いないんですけど
本当はね 勝手に言います
私に何か桁違い能力がある
で 周りみんなにそこまでない
何されると思う？馬鹿にされる
非難される それは世の中の常です
である程度歌える人がいて
抜群にその能力がある人がいると
やっぱり嫌なんですね
だって自分が歌える 周りで一緒に歌っている人々も
それほど 何て言います？歌唱力ない
音はない 気持ちいいんですよ
俺にできるぞと じゃ 気持ち悪いでしょ
世界は いくつかの短所もあった方が良いですから
身の安全です 何かなにかみんなに非難される
認めない何かあった方がいいんです
だから私は時々あえて乱暴な日本語を使ったり
社会で説法では使ってはいけない言葉を使ったりもします
結構みんな嫌な顔をしているのはわかりますけど
私は自分の短所としてそれを大事に守っているんです
普通生ぬるい日本語を喋れますよ
でもあえて間違った変な社会で人の前で使ってはいけない言葉とかね
覚えたら言っちゃう だからなんか変でしょ
社会は そういうなんか変なところあると
弱いところあると それで見といてくれるんです
変じゃない？変なところない
もう非難するところない
ないと潰されます 日本でも言葉あるんだけど
ぴったし合わないんだけどね
出るくぎは打たれるとかね
それなんですね だから釘出てもいいんだけど
ちょっと曲げて曲がった方です
これもうちょっと直した方がいいんじゃないとかね
言われるようにね した方がいいです
はい タイトルは最後に個人の疑問はですね
はい 次 全く別なテーマ
個人が忘れること 我々個人で大事なことを忘れるんですね
他人に認めることだけを要求する人生は惨めです
認めてほしいね ものすごく愚劣と惨めな
だから認めなくてもいいんじゃないという態度も必要なんです
だから認めてほしいと同時に
認めなくても構いませんよと
この両方を持たなくちゃいけない
なぜならば 世の中は完全に自分を称賛しません
完全に非難することも不可能なんです
だから両方来るんです
認めてほしい 認めてほしいと思っている人々は
この非難されるセクションをカットするんです
パイナップル買うと あのギザギザの頭のところと
あの触ったらなんかすごい気持ち悪い
皮と一緒に買わなくちゃいけないでしょ
あの甘いパイナップル実だけではありえません
そういう風には成長しませんよ
パイナップルってみんなに食べられるんだから
カラスとかね カラスも食べますよ
リスとかね だからパイナップルは自分を身を守るために硬い
食べたら怪我するぐらいの硬い皮を持っているんです
虫たちにも降りにくい
あの上 なんか葉っぱの一部があるんですね
パイナップル買う場合は
それ全部まとめて買わなくちゃいけないんです
魚買ったら骨もあるんです
鱗もあるんです はい それで次のポイント
自分も他人を認めてあげなくてはならない
それを忘れるんです 認めてくれ
認めてくれと言う前に
自分が人を認める これが欠けているんですよ
世の中 私にも欠けていると思いますけど
私は自分勝手で能力だったら何の躊躇もなく認められるんですね
他ですねって感じで すごい能力あるとものすごい
そこはもうすごく心から認める
でもそれ私は良くないと思います
何でも認めなくちゃいけないんですよ
ちょっとのことをやっても
それを認めてあげましょう
素直に簡単に他を認めてあげる性格の人は皆に好かれます
日本の社会ではそんなに珍しいことじゃないんですよ
いつでもよくできましたとか
ありがとうとかね 上手ですねとかね
これでOK これで完璧とかね
なんとかいろいろ言葉で人を認めましょう
この認める性格を育てましょう
他人を認める性格 それで仏教の世界ではいうのは
どんな人間にも どんな生命にも何か短所短所ではなくて長所長所があるんです
だからそこを発見して認めましょう
そうするとこの問題 完全解決です
本当に今日のテーマ ただ
それで終わるはずない
終わってもいいのです
承認欲求ということでは
解決策はたった一つ あなたは人を認めなさい
どんな人でも何かいいところがあるんです
犯罪者にでも調べたら何かいいこと何かあるんですよ
本能である他を見下す気持ちをなくしましょう
この人を見下すことというのは生命の本能なんです
私はずっと動物を観察したんですけどね
結構相手のことを見下すんですね
動物は自分の間に それでせいぜいまあお互い 1ヶ月住んでいたんだから
もう野良犬のヴィパッサナーの周りでも動かないんですね
走りの間で走ってくるし
もう一匹の家に飼っている犬なんですけど
来て私を衣をきちっと噛みしめて引っ張るんですね
犬が細かったんで ものすごい力
倒れるんです あなた何やってるのかなと
聞いてくれ 聞いてくれない
それでお互い喧嘩する
お互い見下したりする
見下したりすることは気持ち悪くなったところで
私のところに来て 私って可愛いでしょうと顔をする
全然可愛くないです だからそこで私は何を学んだかというと
この他を見下すということは我々の本能なんですね
だって楽でしょ 見下すことは簡単でしょ
褒めることといったら
うーん ちょっと恥ずかしいと言うでしょ
それですよ ポイントは
見下すことが恥ずかしくなっちゃう
褒めることが自然 素直になるまで人格を直しましょう
それで問題は完璧に終わります
はい 次に認め方にいきます
他人をありのままに です
あんまりストレスをくちゃはいてますが
お母さんたちよくやるでしょ？子供たち何か描くだけみたいな
あー上手上手 すごい上手です
あれがかなり危険です
みんな下手だから そういう風に余計に褒めるんです
私は子供たちがちっちゃな何か描いて
先生の顔を描いたとか持ってきたってもね
だから私にとっては 子供が一生懸命描いたところは可愛い
でも子供だからね 何のこともないんだけどね
そこで私はすごい客観的に認めるんですね
私 だから親から上手ですねというよりはね
私はこれはこうなってね
面白いねとかね なんでこちらこういうふうにしたんですか？とかね
それで子供の質問や あ
そうですか よくわからなかったねとかね
私の褒め方はそういう褒め方なんです
で それで子供はさらに勉強に励みますからね
ですから ありのままに認めた方がいいんですね
難しいかもしれませんけど
悪いところを言う時でも
その人の良いところも言わなくてはならないんです
だから あんたダメ なぜこんなことやるもんかい
それはダメなんですね
子供やなんてスポーツやっている子はすごく元気で能力あるんだけどもね
問題ないんだけどね 勉強もちょっとやらなきゃ不完全だよ
という風に言った方が非難にならないんですね
何かいいところも言って
例えば人おかしいことをやったんだけど
全くダメですね 認めるわけにはいきません
ダメだ これはではなくて
あなた一生懸命頑張ったね
でも頑張っただけで ちょっと初めからちょっと勘違いあったみたいで
これはちょっと役に立ちませんだからこういう風にもうちょっとやり直してくれる
そしてその人は自分が一生懸命頑張ったことは認めているんだけど
結果は却下っていうことを落ち着いてるんですね
そうすると能力は上がるんですよ
批判と非難の区別をして批判のみを実行する
批判と非難というのはすごく
違うんです 同じじゃないんです
批判というのはデータに基づいて評価することなんです
評価して点数を入れる
それは批判であって 非難というのは感情的で
相手をダメだと断定している
いわゆるもう頭ごなしに否定すると
非難は良くない 非難は悪口です
感情でギャーギャーギャーギャーギャーギャーという
データに基づいてこれでこれでこれだからよくないでしょ
だからこういうことやめなさい
というふうに 我々は批判上手になっていいんですが
非難は絶対やらない方がいいです
人を慈しむ 認める性格を育てる
だから 全ての生命に対して優しい気持ちを持っていると
まあ長所を見つけて短所も示して教えてあげることはできるのです
はい それが認め方なんですね
次に学び方にいきます
だから人間学ぶ羽目になっちゃったんだから
この承認の問題が出たんですよ
だから学び方 誰からでも何かを学べるものがあります
仏教を学ぶならば 仏教が皆様の役に立つと思うならば
このことを覚えておきましょう
誰からでも何か学ぶものがあります
動物たちから学べるものがある
これ発見しましょう 学ぶものって 2つでしょ？あ
これいいなとかね 肯定的に見る
これはあかんと否定的に見るというね
2つあります すぐ喧嘩を売る人がいる
ほんのちょっとのことで喧嘩
そういう人から学べるものがありますよ
これ 自分をやるためじゃなくて
自分がやらないためにやらない
やってはいけないことは何かとその人から学べるんです
ホームレスになっている人がいます
その人と話し合ってみると
人間はやってはいけないことを結構学べるんです
だから世界は誰だって教えてくれるんですよ
自然 動物 植物 いろんなところから学べる
それから子供からいろんなものを学べる
何をするべきか するべきではないか
どのようにするべきかなどを他人から学べるんです
こういうのはすべて他人から学ばなくちゃいけない
自分の判断では信頼できないんです
するべきもの してはいけないもの
どのようにやるのか どのようにやってはいけないのか
この 4つ他人から学ぶ
親にも子供から学べるものがあるんです
死ぬまで学ぶ精神を持つ人は幸福です
すごい楽しいんですよ
はい それで学び方が終わりました
はい 次 そろそろ終わりたいと思いますと
いくつかあります 誰に求められるべきでしょうか
と だから求めることはもう自然で当たり前だと話しているんだからね
認めてもらわなきゃもう生きられませんから
では すべての生命に認めてもらうのがありえない
ありえない 決してありえない
この社会的な人物でも
みんな認めるわけじゃない
ノーベル賞まで取ったっても
世界的な人間になるでしょう
でもみんな認めるわけじゃない
ですから これです 自分が学びたい事柄のプロに認められるべきです
お箏の 演奏したければ
そのプロのところで認めてもらう
私の前でお箏 箏を弾いて演奏して
どうですかね？認めますかね
認めます 何で言わないの？その人
その私が手紙を書いてくれたっても
これを見せても商売にならないんですね
スマナサーラ坊主が私の演奏はとてもいいと言ってるんだけど
効き目がないんです だから
それは小刀の有名なプロがOKしたからです
だからそこを考えましょう
しかし 人間には物事の一部しか教えてあげることはできませんので
他人に自分の人生を完全に任せてはいけませんです
お琴の先生は琴の琴 琴の練習を教えるかもしれませんだけど
料理のことを教えられませんね
服 着物を着方を教えられませんとか
いろいろあります だから
この世の中で人間というのは誰だって何か一つだけ学んでいます
一つ 二つ そこプロです
他はわからない だから
この完全に他人に依存することをやめましょう
その人が知っていることだけ学んで
そこから認証してもらって
他まだ学びたいければ
別なプロのところに行かなきゃいけない
これもよくある失敗で
若い人々は大学なんかに入っちゃうと
大学の先生とかは気に入っちゃったらこの信仰するんですね
信仰して その先生がやってる何でもかんでも学んでしまいます
これ危険です 人間だから
いくらなんでもいけないところはいっぱいあるんですね
だから そのプロとしての能力あるところだけ学べばよろしいのです
完全に任せてはいけません
人生は 任せますけど 部分的に
はい そこ 次は優れた道というテーマで仏教の話をします
性格 人格 生き方 道徳 心理
幸福への道を教えられる先輩に頼るべきです
いくらなんでも科学者であろうか
芸術家であろうか 人間で生きているんです
だから すべての生命に共通なのは生きているんです
犬も生きているんです
だから犬も生き方を知った方がいいんです
人間も正しい生き方を知った方がいいんです
楽器演奏できてもできなくても大したことじゃないんです
数学できてもできなくても大したことはないんです
誰だって生きてる ですから
このすべての生命に欠かせないもの
性格 人格 生き方 道徳 心理
事実は何なのか？それから幸福への道
誰だって幸福になりたいでしょ
そういうものを教えられる先輩がいるならば
さっさと頼った方がいいです
そこでまあ 何といいますか
一言でというんですかね
何の躊躇もなく そういう人に頼った方がいい
ブッダは理性のある人に認められる生き方を推薦します
お釈迦様は認められる生き方をしなさいとはっきり言っているんです
例えば我々は戒律を守っているんだけど
あんまりにも膨大で覚えていないんですね
だからいろいろ工夫してすべて把握できる
基本的なところで身を守っているんですね
その場合は お釈迦様がおっしゃっているのは
他の出家者たちに批判されないように気をつけてください
批判されない だから私は戒律を守っているぞと言ってはいけないのです
他のお坊さんが ああ こいつはね
結構真面目に頑張っているんだと
戒律というのは個人のことでしょ
お釈迦様もそれさえも他人に任せているのです
サンガが認めてくれなきゃダメなんです
そこで私の師匠だけじゃなくて
もう同じ年齢の出家でも
年下の出家でも 誰にも構いません
その人々が認められるならば
まあいいということになります
ですから この場合はバカに認められたって面白くないんです
アホに悪人に じゃなくて
理性のある人格者に認められることを考えて
人格者に認められなかったら落ち込んでもいいんです
人格者だから人を見下しませんよ
客観的に見ているんです
ありのままに だから人格者ありのまま見てあっち向いているならば
自分がアウトなんです
常識が認められたって無視すればいいんです
人格者ではないんだから
はい 次はブッダの言葉
ヤンチェーウィンニューパサンサンティアヌヴィッチャスウェースウェーアッチッドブッティンメーダーインパンニャーシーラサマヒタ
理性のある人は毎回あるいは毎日確認して称賛する
知恵と道徳を備えた隙間のない生き方をする
だからこれはサンガの中の生き方を言ってますけど
サンガの優れた先輩たちがよく調べているんです
微妙 どれぐらい我々は監視されるのかというと
衣をちょっと落ちてると
これ何ですか？と聞かれる
ご飯食べる時でも手の置き方がちょっと間違ったら
ちょっと何だこれは と言われますよ
だから そういう理性の社会にいると微妙に観察されるんですよ
回り方 それで何も文句を言わない
言えないように自分を育てるんです
その場合の自己管理は必要です
私は小さい時からものすごく走るんですよ
出家してから走る走る
歩くということはなかったんです
どうしても走る でも出家して走ってはいけないんですね
それも知っているんですね
だから私はまあ師匠にまあ怒られないような走り方をするんです
これは見ているんですね
だからガキだからまあ仕方がないとね
まああるところはあって
でもたまたま言うんですね
まあ出家っていうのはね
本当はあの歩幅はこれこちらか
これぐらいの歩幅で歩くんだけどねとか言ってくれくれます
それからこの道徳とね
知恵っていうのはこっちの
世界 それを備えて隙間のない生き方をしなさい
ということは 批判 非難はなし
非難はすごい少ない 批判はね
生き方をしなさい 純金のようなその人を誰か非難する
梵天さえもその人のことを称賛します
この偈の続きでありまして
230でお釈迦様がこれを隙間のない人は純金のような人
社会がだらしないんだけど
世界はだらしないんだけど
非難できなくなるんだよ
人間のところから梵天の神々さえも
そのような人を認めて褒めます
この最後のタイトルは善友カリアン
善友とは智慧と道徳を備えた人です
誰でも善人になります
人間に智慧があって 理性があって
道徳で悪いことをしない
悪行為しない その人は善人です
友達じゃないんです 我々一般的に言う友達じゃないんです
善人というのはちょっと違うんですね
大体善人というのはいつでも目上の人になるんです
だから皆様にも大学で
学校で善友の先生方がいたかもしれない
善友先生は善友だったらもう抜群
自分が成長するんです
この資格が完成しているのはブッダと阿羅漢たちです
ブッダは人類の善友です
善友に認められる生き方をすると
解脱に達するまで人は成長します
完成の道ですよ 善友っていうのはブッダ
お釈迦様 大本 お釈迦様に認められる生き方をしなくてはいけないんです
私もいつでもいろんな変なことをやってますけど
お釈迦様にバレたらどう言われるのかといつでも考えちゃうんです
こんなことを知ったらね
くったくた言われるでしょうとかね
昨日スライドを作らなくちゃいかんだけど 12
時半まで夜ネットでいろいろ見てたんです
自分の仕事をやらなきゃ何やってるのかっていうことになりますけど
はい これパーリ語でカリャーナミッタと言うんですね
覚えた方がいいんですよ
あの 一回この三日 二回ありましてね
アナンド尊者がなんかアイデアが浮かんでいてね
善友がいれば仏道の半分進みます
解脱の道半分ぐらい進みます
いいアイデアだからお釈迦様に言ったんですよ
お釈迦様は何者もそんなことを絶対言ってはいけません
善友に出会えば仏道は完成します
そこでサーリプッタ尊者にも同じアイデアが出たんです
サーリプッタ尊者がこう考える
善友がいれば人間が解脱に達するんだからね
仏道は完成するんだよ
仏道完成したければ善友でしょう
いて お釈迦様にそれを言ったんです
お釈迦様がその通りでした
智慧の第一人者だからね
アナンダ尊者は違いますからね
しょうがないんです アナンダ尊者が言ったことは否定されちゃったんですけど
マハーカッサパ大尊者が言ったらその通りです
善友さえいれば仏道は完成します
と言ったので だからこの善友っていう言葉は
仏教ではとても大事な言葉
善友とは証人ですよ それから逃げられません
善友が私を承認する 免除する
大学の卒業証明書と同じですよ
はい 結論に行きましょうか
これからが結論 完全独立はあり得ません
完全依存も危険 危険です
区別能力を駆使して他人に認められる生き方をしなくてはいけない
専有に完全に認められるよう
専有がいれば完全に認めてほしいと思っているじゃない
解脱しただけ 完全独立です
完全独立 認めても認めてくれなくてもどうでもいいって
その次元が破っちゃうんです
それが解脱に達することです
はい これで決勝盤ですからね
まあ手順は言う必要ないです
では ありがとうございます
先生 ありがとうございます
あと十五分ほど時間ございます
ちょっと短い時間なんですけど
もし質問等ある方いらっしゃいましたら
挙手していただきましたらマイクを回しますがいかがでしょうか？ちょっと目があんまり良くないので
ああ じゃあはい  先生の先ほどのお話の中で
道徳が教えられるような人に頼るべきであるというふうなお言葉がございましたが
社会というのは 道徳がある人と道徳がない人
これはどちらの数が多いのか教えていただきたいと思います
あともし仮に道徳がない人の方が多いという場合は
これ多数決の原理を導入しますと
道徳がある人というのは社会から承認されない
なかなか承認されにくいというふうになると思いますが
そのような理解でよろしいでしょうか
教えてください  道徳ということにはいろいろニュアンスありまして
社会は道徳なしって社会は成り立たないんです
道徳なければもう野生ですよ
例えば文化 文明とか何とか
いろんな決まり 守らなくちゃいけないものっていっぱい出ているんですよ
例えば法律を守ることも一つの道徳なんですよ
だから道徳を否定する社会組織っていうのはありえないんで
ヤクザでも同じ 何々組とかね
我々にとって迷惑かもしれませんだけど
その中でいろんなしきたり
厳しいんですね だからそこら辺を理解した方がいいんですよ
問題は ヤクザたちが自分たちでこの極道の人々を守っている道徳は
社会は認めないんですね
マフィアの人々にも道徳ありますけど
自分勝手な道徳 でも 社会から見れば
社会の人々へっちゃで殺しちゃうんですね
これは認めない だから
ある会社の決まりは別なところで認めない場合もありますね
だから この一部だけ一部で認められて
一部で認められない道徳っていうのは
本当に情け 弱くていい加減で条件付きで大したことではありません
例えば 受験する人はカニングしてはいけないでしょ
カニングって盗むことでしょ
盗むことで嘘をつくこと
だから試験がありますよと言った時点で
もう道徳成り立ってるんですよ
道徳は否定できません
道徳っていうのは正しいやり方
何にしたっても正しいやり方があるんです
例えば このホールを我々はある時間決めて借りたんですよ
その時間以内で我々は出て行かなくちゃいけないんですね
それさえも道徳なんです
では 机なんか潰すとは壊してはいけないしね
これはドカンドカンで床に叩いてはいけないしね
いっぱいあるでしょ 見てみれば
そこで問題が問題考えたところは
なんとなく日本の社会でも道徳を無視する
否定することもあるんじゃないかなとかね
思ってる そう感じるところはあると思いますけど
みんなね あの 例えば多数決をね
もうそんなに信頼できませんよ
何か決められる じゃあみんなどうですかと手を挙げて下さいと言ったら
もうもう過半数ですから決めますとかね
これはまあ仕方がないんだけど
完全に信頼できません
例えば人がいるところで一人だけすごいまとめなことを言う
みんなこんなこと言ったってもやりたくない
やりたい やっぱり一人の人の意見に従った方がいいとは思いますよ
曖昧冗談ぱな場合は多数決で言っちゃいますけど
だからといってそれって完全に正しい答えでもないんですね
みんな一つの意見になった方がすごく信頼はありますね
とにかく道徳はいろいろランクがありまして
学校の道徳 会社の道徳
家族の中の道徳とかあります
自分のグループの中の道徳が安定か不安定か調べる方法は
他の組織に社会全体的に認められるかないかなんです
だから ある会社が自分会社の仲間内でいろんな決まりを作っても
これは社会は認めないならば
これは危険です 家族で自分たちで規則決まりますね
この決まった家族だけなんですね
でも 第三者がそれを聞いたら
おお いいですね これはそういう決まりでみんな仲良くしてるのいいですよと認めたら OK なんですね
なんかあんた方変なことやってるんじゃない？と言われたら
こちらうちのことだからね
放っておいてくれと言えますよ
放っておいてくれと 家族のことだからと言えますけど
家族と関係ない他人がこれはすごいと言った方がいいんです
だからいつでも我々はいろんな組織を作って
道徳を決めたり やり方を決めたりするんだけど
いつでも周りから見てもいいことですねと言われるようにしましょう
それでこの道徳の問題を解決する
仏教になってくると 我々は心を清らかにするんだからね
怒り 嫉妬 憎しみ 心から排除しようと言っているんだから
一般社会では守らない
守らないが守れます 道徳は教えています
仏教が語る道徳は どんな社会でも
どんな人間にも守られます
しかし 我々はもうすごい煩悩のせいで守りたくないと思っているんです
それも理解しておきましょう
仏教は正しいことを言っているんだからといってね
世界はみんな認めるわけじゃないんですからね
はい その程度で答えてよろしいですか
ありがとうございました
ということで じゃああと一人ある方ですか
えーとですね 人を承認する承認欲求を込めて満たしてあげるということはですね
自律者でいうとムディターにも相当すると思うんですけども
諸情動論とか自律者の近くの敵と遠くの敵というのがあって
遠くの敵の場合は怒りですとか
嫌いですとか 嫉妬とかだと分かりやすいんですけども
ムディターの場合は近くの敵はすぐ楽なんですね
それでその説明では 他人
他人の幸せっていうか
例えばボールを手にするスポーツか
すごいスポーツが持ってる人だとして
その人の そういう持っているいいものを褒め称えることと同時にですね
自分がこう 自分もなんかこう
そういうものを何か働くに当たって得たらいいなと思ってしまうと
そのスッカのところでせっかくムジタの瞑想をしたのに
スッカの近くの敵にやられちゃうことになると思って
そのムジタをやるにあたって
その近くの敵のスッカを通り抜けるためには
通り抜けてこうやり過ごすためにはどのようにしたらよろしいでしょうか
質問はあまりよく理解が私には理解できないんだけど
ありますかね 質問されたかと
えーと ムジタのその遠くの敵と近くの敵があって
近くの敵の場合は  まあとにかくあなた
このその枠から離れたらどうですかね
なんかややこしい枠にはめられているんですよ
このヴィスッティマグガのね
説明とかね 今日のテーマはヴィスッティマグガじゃないんです
経典にはあるんです お釈迦様はね
いつでも使っているパーリ単語はワンナなんです
ワンネイティっていうのは褒めるって意味なんです
慈悲喜捨じゃないんです
そこでプレイス 英語で言えばね
プレイス 褒める 褒める時は
我々道徳として必ず人を客観的に見て
褒めるべきところは必ず褒めなさいと
批判するべきところは客観的に相手に役に立つように批判しなさいと
それを破っちゃうととんでもない人間になると
いわゆる自分の利益のために褒める
褒めるところは褒めるべきところではない
だから褒める時 褒めるべきところを褒めない
批判するべきところは批判しないと
これは非道徳的な生き方なんです
これ 出勤は厳しく決められてあります
そういうセクションは浄土論には入ってないんです
慈悲喜捨にこだわりたければ
これはメッターとウペッカーなんです
間じゃないんです 私は今日使ってないですよ
慈悲喜捨 テーマが違うんです
で これは師弟関係のようなものなんですね
師弟関係の場合は ブッダが師匠だったらもう完全に従っちゃうというところで
ブッダに認めること これどう？これはどう？とブッダにいつでも聞いて
まあよく頑張った ダメですよ
もっと頑張れとかね いう風にお釈迦様に批判もされるし
あるところでお坊さんたちがずっと頑張って瞑想して
ものくたくた疲れちゃって祈り捨てていたんですね
お釈迦様出て行ったんです
ホールから出て行ったところで
もう説法も聞いて疲れちゃって居眠りしていたんです
それを狙っていたのお釈迦様は
また入ってきたんです
入ってきてものすごく叱ったんです
よく寝るんだよと あんた方は
真夜中ですよ すべて燃えているのに
よくもよかむりで寝るんだよと
だから まあそういうふうに
それでお坊さんたちは
やっぱりお釈迦様に言われたということで
もう一つエピソードを言いますよ
サーリプッタ尊者がかなり地方で伝道活動をして
若者はたくさん出家しちゃったんです
それでサーリプッタ尊者が教えてあげて
もう君たちはね 我々のブッダ見たことないでしょうと
会いましょうと もう何ヶ月間もかけて歩いて歩いて歩いて歩いてウェーサーリーに行っちゃったんです
ウェーサーリーに行って
すごいものすごく疲れてるんで
この若い人々は ただ お寺
お寺って言ったって 政府の建物です
だけどね そちらでお坊さんたちはいる場所を分けてあげなくちゃいけない
そこでこの管理する坊員たちは
もうあんた あんた方 ここここと場所を分けるところで
みんな大騒ぎして大騒ぎ
ちょっと喋っちゃった
じゃあ私はこちらで あんたこちら
あんたこちら これ お釈迦様は喋る声出していけないんですね
どんな顔してても静かでやらなくちゃいけない
ただ お釈迦様 なんでこの魚売り場みたいな声だと
上司先の人が来ているんですかと
だから漁師という言葉もすごい非難の単語なんです
だから いい 地方からお坊さんたちが来て
場所を取りにちょっと大騒ぎ
出て行きなさいと お釈迦様会ってないんです
追い出しますからと指令しちゃったんです
言ったら お釈迦様に退治命令出ましたよと
言った途端 サーリプッタ尊者が何のことなく
君たち荷物まとめましょうと
帰りましょうと 何のことなく帰っていくんです
だからそういうところなの
他人に認めるか非難されるかというサーリプッタ尊者さえも文句言わなかったんですね
なんでやと こんな遠くから来てね
この若者 お釈迦様に会いたくて必死やと
ないんです 完全たる師匠だから
退治退治です そこでウェーサーリの国をやっている王子たちがお坊さんたちたくさん来るんだから
明日はご飯作らなくちゃいかんやと考えているところで
また出ていくんですね
言ったら サーリプッタ先生
なんですぐ帰るんですか？と
で 釈尊に退治命令出ましたから
そこで在家の方々はさっさとお釈迦様のところに行って
お釈迦様 あの若者たちだからね
いきなりこんな厳しいことを言ったってもまずいんじゃない？みんな仏道に興味を失うかも知れませんよと
だからちょっと叱って教えてあげてください
そうじゃ 入れないでくださいと
退治命令を簡単にまた解除
それでまた入ってくるんですね
だから ああいうところで何の文句もなく従う
それは師匠がブッダだからなんです
そういうことで この社会に認められる
認められないという そういういろいろ条件がありますよ
そこで我々は完璧じゃないんだから
まあいろいろ認めることも
非難されることも 両方我々は受け取らなくちゃいけないんですね
だからこの これはメッタ
みんな同じやと ウペッカー
人間は 生命は様々やと
例えば犬に餌をあげると
飼っているんじゃなくて
例えば野良犬に餌をあげると
野良犬に噛まれる可能性もあります
だからといって怒ってはならんです
私はお寺にいた時は この猫を二匹が来て
体の上にいつでももう追い出しても追い出しても出ていかない
それで無理やり横に入れちゃって
こちら寝なさいと そして本を読んでいて
ちょっと体が回ったりすると噛むんです
何するのかと ね 寝ることに邪魔したんだからと言って
私を見たら 私は楽しかったんで
噛まれちゃって なんでやというと
なんか私があいつらのベッドやと思ってるんですね
人間じゃないベッドも好き勝手に使ってもいい
だからこの人間ベッドが動くちゃう
迷惑でしょ？グッとかんでね
だからそういういろいろ性格があるんです
そこで私はウペッカーで
まあそちらはその考えで
こちらはこの考えでということで落ち着くんですね
だからこのメッターとウペッカーですね
で 実践するんで あんたの問題やるのは
あんたメッターやっている時はやられたっていうことはね
まあそれはあなたに欠点があるんですよ
ちょっと調子に乗りやがったと思いますよ
相手に問題あるわけじゃないんです
いくらメッターでムディターでジヒキシャでやっちゃっても
この野郎 お前もう見たくはないと言われる人間がいるんです
その中で ああ そうな どうもありがとうございますという気持ち
人格がね 必要なんです
だからそれ以上は喋ることないんです
じゃ  それではそろそろ時間になりましたので
終了したいと思います
最後に誓願 はい 皆様 この誓願の文句を唱えましょう
ドゥッカッパッターチェニン・ドゥッカ
バーヤンパッターチェニン・バーヤー
ソーカムパッターチェニン・ソーカ
ホントゥサンディーティ・パーニノー
苦しんでいるあらゆる生命が苦しむなく
恐れて悩む生命が恐れなく
悲しんで悩む生命が悲しむなく
一切の生命が安穏でありますように
はい ありがとうございます
皆さん ありがとうございました
これで本日の諸仏教月例講演会を終了いたします